[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع ليلى الاختيار السهلوها بابرز
العرب
اكثر من 700 الف متظاهر ضد نظام التقاعد
في فرنسا
على التعديل
[موسيقى]
يعتبر عوده واشنطن الى المبادئ المتحضره
بين الدول شرطا الاستئناف الحوار
مذكره استدعاء لوزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
للمثول امام الكونجرس بسبب الانسحاب من
افغانستان
وتحذيرات من تمكن الذكاء الاصطناعي من
العالم 300 مليون وظيفه مهدده عالميا
[موسيقى]
ازمه مستمره طوال اسابيع مضت شد وجذب بين
المواطنين الفرنسيين ورئيسهم الذي يصر على
تعديل نظام التقاعد احتجاجات مستمره
واشتباكات في مدن فرنسيه عده نتابع
مشاهدينا تفاصيلها اليوم في التاسعه هذا
المساء
[موسيقى]
اذا نبدا التاسعه هذا المساء من فرنسا
التي شهدت يوما عاشرا من التظاهرات ضد
اصلاح نظام التقاعد الذي تقابله معارضه
شعبيه كبيره حيث وصلت اعداد المحتجين في
العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس الى 740 الف
متظاهر وفقا طبعا الشرطه الفرنسيه وفي
تعزيزات غير مسبوقه اعلنت وزاره الداخليه
انها نشرات 13 الف شرطي بينهم 5500 في
باريس وحدها وشهدت الاحتجاجات اشتباكات
بين الشرطه والمتظاهرين في باريس فيما
احرق المتظاهرون مصرفا في مدينه نات ما
ادى الى مواجهات عنيفه مع الشرطه وكانت
نقابات عماليه قد طالت الرئيس الفرنسي
بوقف خطته الراميه الى رفع سن التقاعد
ولكن الحكومه رفضت هذه المطالب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مشروع اصلاح نظام التقاعد يرفع الحد
الادنى لسن التقاعد من 62 الى 64 عاما
يفقد بعض العاملين في القطاع العام
امتيازاتهم
يرفع عدد سنوات العمل المطلوبه للتاهل
لمعاش تقاعديا كامل لماذا يهتم الفرنسيون
كثيرا بقانون التقاعد ينظر اليه كحجر
الزاويه لنموذج الحمايه الاجتماعيه
يدفع العاملون رسوم الرواتب لتمويل معاشات
المتقاعدين
يحصل جميع العمال الفرنسيين على معاش
تقاعديه
تعد فرنسا من الدول الاوروبيه التي تعتمد
ادنى سنا للتقاعد
حاول كافه الرؤساء المتعاقبين اجراء
تغييرات على قوانين التقاعد
غالبا تشعل غضب الشارع وتنعكس سلبا في
صناديق الاقتراع
لنقل الصوره من فرنسا ينضم الينا من باريس
حسين قنيبر مدير مكتب العربيه في فرنسا
وينضم الينا ايضا من باريس فادي الداهوك
مراسل العربيه سابدا معك باليوم العاشر
للتظاهرات والاحتجاجات على التي عمت
الشوارع الفرنسيه كيف هي الصوره من هناك
نعم ليال ما زال عدد كبير من المتظاهرين
هنا في ساحه لاناسيون الامه متواجدين
وهناك مناوشات تحدث مع الشرطه كما ترون
على الشاشه هناك استخدام للغاز المسيل
للدموع بالاضافه الى ان هناك بعض الحرائق
التي يشعلها المتظاهرون هناك حشد امني
كثيف حقيقه الان يحاولون تفريق ما تبقى من
المتظاهرين هذه التظاهرات التي جمعت
450,000 بحسب النقبات فقط في العاصمه
باريس او في العاصمه وحدها لكن النقابات
تتحدث عن حواله او عن اكثر من مليونير
متظاهر في عموم فرنسا طبعا قبل قليل ايضا
انتهى اجتماع للنقبات وفي مؤتمر صحفي
اعلنوا ان التحرك المقبل سوف يكون في
السادس من شهر ابريل المقبل سيكون ايضا
يوما للتظاهر
والاضراب هناك الان حاله من الفوضى هنا في
هذه الساحه هناك عناصر متجمعه من الشرطه
باعداد كبيره يطلق الغاز المسيل للدموع
كما ترون عبر المتظاهرين الذين يحاولون
ابعاد هذه القنابل وقذفها باتجاه عناصر
الشرطه وايضا يستخدمون الحجاره
نحاول الابتعاد قليلا
عن الغاز
فادي ابقي لنا الصوره مفتوحه لو سمحت
سانتقل الى الزميل حسين قنيبر حسين يعني
توصيف خطوره ما يحصل في فرنسا اليوم بعد
اوساط ماكرونز ذهبت الى اعتبار ان ما يحصل
شبيه بعماي
19588 الى اي مدى اليوم فرنسا يعني امام
مرحله مفصليه
ربما المناسب ليال مساء الخير اولا ان
نقارن ما يحصل اليوم بما حصل في الولايه
الاولى للرئيس الفرنسي الاسبق جاك شيراك
الرئيس الراحل خصوصا في عهد حكومته الاولى
التي تراسها
حينها عام 95
سجلت في فرنسا تظاهرات شارك فيها الملايين
تشبه تلك التي تحصل منذ مطلع هذا العام
والتي كان محورها الاعتراض على اصلاح
النظام التقاعد ما يحصل اليوم اخطر ما فيه
انه لا يلوح في الافق اي مخرج من هذه
الازمه فالحكومه اذا تراجعت وطبعا من
خلفها الرئيس ماكرون اذا تراجع
سيبدوان ضعيفين وسيبدوان كانهما تراجعات
تحت ضغط الشارع واذا لم يتراجع فان الازمه
ستصبح مفتوحه على كل الاحتمالات ومن بينها
المزيد من العنف في الشارع يعول على امرين
اما الوساطه التي اقترحت النقابات ان تقوم
بها جهه ما بينها اي بين النقبات والحكومه
وهو ما لم تتحمس له الحكومه التي قال
الناطق باسمها انه لا توجد حاجه الى وسيط
بين النقابات والحكومه بل بامكان الجهتين
ان يتحاورا مباشره ولكن هذا لا يبدو وشيكا
الليالي لان رئيسه الوزراء اليزابيث بورن
التي قالت امس بعد اجتماع في قصر الاليزيه
برئاسه ماكرون انها مستعده للتهدئه مع
النقبات وستستقبل قاده احزاب المعارضه
مطلع الشهر المقبل عادت بورن وقالت اليوم
بعد تصريحات نقابيه دعت الى الوساطه بين
النقابات والحكومه قالت بورن ان الحكومه
لا يمكنها ان تعلق تطبيق اصلاح نظام
التقاعد الذي سيبدا تنفيذه في سبتمبر
المقبل لا تراجع حكوميا حتى الان ويعول
على راي المجلس الدستوري الذي سيعطي رحله
في قانون رفع سته التقاعد خلال ثلاثه
اسابيع احسن اسمح لي ان اعود الى الزميل
فادي على ما يبدو ان المواجهات يعني
احتدمت هناك بين المتظاهرين والشرطه فاديه
هل مازلت تسمعنا
نعم
نعم اسمعك ليا الان المواجهات ما زالت
مستمره الغاز المسيل الدموع ما زال ايضا
يطلق من قبل عناصر الشرطه تطلقه بكثافه
لتفريق المحتجين هنا في هذه الساحه في
ساحه لاناسيو المتظاهرون الذين بقيوا هنا
حتى الان هم من شريحه الشبان في اغلبهم
وهم ما زالوا يقفون في هذه الساحه يرفضون
المغادره طبعا طلبه الشرطه او فتحت بعض
الممرات لمن يريد المغادره وبالفعل غادر
عدد من المتظاهرين لكن هؤلاء مازال هناك
كما ترون هم يرفضون الخروج من هذه الساحه
برغم قيام الشرطه باستخدام الغاز المسيل
للدموع طبعا خلال هذه التظاهرات كان من
المتوقع ان تبدا الاشتباكات في مثل هذه
الساعه او على الاقل في نهايه التظاهره
كان هناك ايضا تحذيرات من قبل وزير
الداخليه جيرالديرمانه من وجود عناصر من
اليسار المتطرف وبعض هؤلاء قال انهم قدموا
من خارج فرنسا راينا بعض هؤلاء خلال
التظاهره وقاموا بالاعتداء على عدد من
المصورين والصحفيين الذين كانوا يغطون هذه
الاحتجاجات قاموا بتحطيم كاميرات كاميرا
لمراسل شبكه سي ان ان على الاقل شبكتين
الامريكيه عندما كان يصور ورفض ان ينزل
الكاميرا او ربما لم يسمعهم هؤلاء يرفضون
طبعا ان يتم تصويرهم حتى لا يتم رصدهم من
قبل قوات الشرطه هو القاء القبض عليهم
لاحقا الان تعود الاشتباكات كما ترون
المتظاهرون يرشقون قوات الشرطه بالحجاره
وبالزجاجات الشرطه تحاول الان تجميع
صفوفها وقد تشن هجوما على هؤلاء
المتضامنين الذين ترونهم على الشاشه
ويرشقون قوات الشرطه بالحجاره
على كل حسين حسين يعني المعلوم اليوم ان
الفرنسيين يرفضون المس بنظام التقاعد الذي
يعتبر حجر الزاويه لنموذج الحمايه
الاجتماعيه هناك ما المقبول يعني بالشارع
اليوم خصوصا ان هناك دوافع اقتصاديه كبيره
امام هذا القرار
نعم في الواقع الحكومه والرئيس يدافعان عن
اصرارهما على تنفيذ قانون اصلاح نظام
التقاعد ورفع سن التقاعد الى 64 عاما من
خلال القول ان النظام التقاعد يعاني من
عجز سيبلغ عام 203020 مليار يورو ولا سبيل
في ضوء ارتفاع معدل اعمار الفرنسيين
المتوسط لاعمار الفرنسيين ارتفع خلال
العقود الاخيره ولا سبيل الى الاستمرار في
دفع التقاعد لهذه الاجيال التي تشيخ في
فرنسا الا من خلال عمل الفرنسيين عامين
اضافيين اما المعترضون على هذا القرار من
جانب الحكومه فيقولون ان بامكانها ان تحصل
اموالا من جوانب اخرى وان توفر في امكنه
اخرى بدل ان تعمد الى فرض هذا الرفع لسن
التقاعد في كل الاحوال المخرج اليوم يبدو
صعبا معقدا من خلال التصعيد الكلامي
المتبادل بين الحكومه والرئيس من جهه
والاحزاب احزاب اليسار والنقابات من جهه
اخرى لا يبدو ان في الافقي حلولا كثيره
اشاره ما دمت تحدثت عن الجانب الاقتصادي
لان خسائر القطاع السياحي والفندقي خلال
اسبوع واحد في باريس بلغت نسبتها ما بين
20 الى 30% تراجعا بالمقارنه مع الحركه
الاعتياديه فيما تراجعت نسبه الاقبال على
السياحه والفنادق في مدن اخرى كمدينه تران
في الغرب بنسبه 60% خلال اسبوع واحد وفي
برضه بنسبه 30% تراجعت الحركه السياحيه
والفندقيه وفي تولوز بنسبه 29 وهذا يعلمه
المتظاهرين بشكل فرنسيين يعني النقبات
والمتطرد البدايه يعلمون بان هذه التحركات
ستشل الاقتصاد الفرنسي ولكن بالنسبه لهم
طبعا الموضوع يعني الضغط على الحكومه هو
اهم بكثير من اي شيء اخر شكرا لكما مدير
مكتب العربيه في باريس حسين قنيبر وايضا
فادي الداهوك مراسل العربيه من باريس
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وزير الداخليه الفرنسيه
مجموعات من المحتاجين بالتورط في اعمال
عنف ضخم سابقا منها تدمير ممتلكات وابتزاز
قوات النظام مشيرا الى انه سيتقدم بحلا
للاحتجاجات في حال وفي اجتماع مجلس
الوزراء المقبل
ارى العنف الشديد لبعض المجموعات الصغيره
كما ترونه انتم والتي اظهرت اجهزه
المخابرات انها مسجله منذ سنوات عديده
كمسؤوله عن اعمال عنف كبيره ومسؤوله عن
عمليات ابتزاز قويه ضد قوات النظام وتدمير
الممتلكات ووقوع مئات الجرحى من رجال
الشرطه نتيجه لتدميرهم لذلك قررت الشروع
في حل للاحتجاجات والذي ساقترحه في جلسه
اجتماع مجلس الوزراء المقبل
لجهه قال الناطق باسم الحكومه الفرنسيه
اوليفيغا بان الدوله تحترم المظاهرات
ولكنها ترفض اعمال العنف
نحن نحترم الاضرابات والمظاهرات ولكننا
سنكون يقظين بشكل خاص للتاكد من انها لا
تؤدي الى اندلاع اعمال عنف جديده وهذا
بفضل التعبئه الاستثنائيه لقواتنا
الاماميه التي نحييها ونحيي كذلك الالتزام
افراد الامن التابعين للمنظمات النقابيه
احترام التظاهرات يعني الاعتراض على العنف
وادانته واولئك الذين يحاولون منحهم شكلا
من اشكال التبرير لا يحتدمون ناخبهم ولا
المؤسسات التي اقسموا على خدمتها وحمايتها
دعا الناطق باسم الحكومه وحكومه الاتحادات
النقابيه الى الحوار المباشر مع الحكومه
الفرنسيه لنقاش المواضيع التي تخص العمل
والتي تهم المواطنين
يمكننا التحدث مع بعضنا البعض مباشره
قالها رئيس الجمهوريه انه مستعد لاستقبال
الاتحادات النقابيه بمجرد ان يعلن المجلس
الدستوري دستوريه نص القانون بعد ذلك يكون
رئيس الوزراء جاهزا لاستقبال النقابات
بشكل مباشر لماذا من المهم القيام بذلك
لانه بالفعل الى جانب اصلاح نظام التقاعد
وقد تحدث رئيس الجمهوريه عن ذلك هناك
العديد من الاشياء التي تحدث والتي تتعلق
بالعمل والتي تهم الفرنسيين
[موسيقى]
يعلق اماله على مشروع قانون السن التقاعد
حتى لا تفلس البلاد
نظام تقاعد الحالي لن يصمد ماليا لا
اموالك فيه من موظفين لدفع مرتبات التقاعد
فرنسا تدفع
14.5% من ناتجها المحلي لبرامج التقاعد
العجز العام في النظام المالي عام 2023
سيصل مليارا و 800 مليون يورو
عام 2025 سيرتفع الى عشره مليارات
و700 مليون يورو عام 2035 سيرتفع الى 21
مليارا و200 مليون يورو فرنسا عن اقتصاديا
من اعلى معدلات الضرائب بالنسبه للناتج
المحلي الاجمالي بنسبه تتجاوز 45%
للحديث اكثر عن هذه الازمه ينضم الينا من
باريس محمد كلاش المحلل السياسي استاذ
محمد يعني اليوم الشارع الفرنسي الذي هو
رافض تماما لتخلي عن المكتسبات الاجتماعيه
التي يعني حصل عليها منذ ايام متقاوه حتى
هذه اللحظه هل الحوار الذي يحمل تنازلات
ممكن ان يحل هذا هذه الازمه
الموضوع ليس موضوع حوار تنازلي بقدر ما هو
موضوع حوار اقناع وهذا ما يؤكد عليه رئيس
ماكرون الذي قالها بصراحه خلال اللقاء
الصحفي معه انه ياسف ياسف لانه لم يقنع
ياسف لانه لم يقنع كفايه وبالتالي فان
الاستراتيجيه استراتيجيه
هو اقناعي ومبدا الشارع وتنازلي وبالتالي
هناك تضارب ليس هناك نقطه التقاء نعم طبعا
طبعا هناك حاله
من التوتر الشديد وحاله من التناقض الكبير
ما بين الجانبين لا لقاء بين الجانبين كل
على موقفه باستثناء ما صدر عن احدى
النقابات امس نقابات السي ام تي
الكونفدراليه الفرنسيه
الديمقراطيه للعمل والتي عرضت ما اسمته
بالوساطه
وكان رد الحكومه الناطق باسم الحكومه اننا
حين نقرر ان نتحدث ان يكون هناك كلام
بيننا اي بمعنى الحوار لسنا بحاجه الى
وساطه اي هو رفض غير مباشر ولو بطريقه
دبلوماسيه لمفهوم الوساطه فيما نقابات
فيما نقابات اخرى كاسيتي مثلا على موقفها
وتصريحات
احد قادتها
الذي قال باننا جاهزون لاشعار لاشعال
النار هذه هذه الجمله قالها حرفيا بعد ان
قال ان
العنف لا يخيفنا لا يخيبنا العنف اذا هناك
حالتان مع الجسم النقابي المتماسك المشكل
حاليا من ثماني نقابات
يعني اعتماد اعتماد حجه
ان اليوم الهدف الاساس من هذه الاصلاحات
هو انحياز فرنسا الى الديمقرا
الديمقراطيات الاوروبيه الاخرى التي تعتمد
سن تقاعد اعلى من المعتمد في فرنسا وايضا
الى الوصول الى مستهدفات على مستوى
الاتحاد الاوروبي اتحدث عن ثلاثه بالمئه
من المستهدفات هل ممكن ان تقنع الشارع
اليوم الذي هو رافض تماما للسماع لاي شيء
يعني ليس المهم بالنسبه الى الشارع الى
النقابات حتى الى الاحزاب خاصه اليساريه
منها موضوع ان تكون فرنسا ضمن الاطار
الاوروبي فيما يخص موضوع
التقاعد بقدر ما يهمها الحاله الفرنسيه
الحاله المواطنيه الفرنسيه الحاله
المواطنيه الفرنسيه فيما يخص موضوع
التقاعد طبعا كان يعني كل الدراسات تؤكد
على ان موضوع التقاعد اذا استمر قانون
التقاعد بما بما هو عليه عند عمر 62 دون
ان
تخفض لاحقا
معاشات التقاعد او ان تزاد الاكتتابات
للتقاعد يعني يزيد العاملون
ما يدفعونه شهريا من معاشاتهم التقاعد
فاننا ذاهبون نحو اسوء وصندوق خصوصا ان
العجز يزيد وايضا يعني هو متوقع بارقام
كبيره استاذ محمد يعني هذا المشروع اعتبره
الرئيس الفرنسي ماكرون كانه رمز لسياساته
الاصلاحيه خصوصا بموضوع النظام التقاعد
كيف سيكون له اثر على حكومته وعلى مستقبل
ولايته طبعا هل سيكون هناك تضحيه باي من
يعني رموز ماكرون اليوم لاهداء الشارع لا
طبعا سيكون له اثر كبير على عمل الحكومات
الفرنسيه اللاحقه على يعني بمعنى انه
سيكون هناك طبعا الحكومه تعمل على
اقرار او على
اعداد مشاريع ترفع الى المجلس النيابي كما
كالعاده لكن اليوم بعد الذي حصل او بعد
الحاصل حاليا في موضوع قانون التقاعد
سيكون امرا صعبا على الحكومات الفرنسيه
اللاحقه اعداد مشاريع قوانين والتوصل الى
نتائج ايجابيه
اليها
داخل البرلمان الفرنسي نعم شكرا لك استاذ
محمد كلاش المحلل السياسي حدثتنا من باريس
اهلا بكم معنا
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
تشدد طالبان مستمر اعتقال ناشط في مجال
تعليم الفتيات
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا قبل ان انتقل
الى الملف الاوكراني ساشير الى هذا العاجل
الذي ورد الان عن النبات الفرنسيه بان
يعني اجمالي المتظاهرين بعموم فرنسا وصل
الى حوالي المليوني متظاهر اذا باليوم
العاشر للتظاهرات الاعداد وصلت الى مليوني
متظاهرين
والان الى الملف الاوكراني حيث اكد وزير
الخارجيه ان على الولايات المتحده ان تعود
الى المبادئ المتحضره للعلاقات بين الدول
من اجل استئناف الحوار مع روسيا وقال في
مقابله مع وكاله الانباء الروسيه تاس انه
يتوجب عليه ان يغيروا او عليهم ان يغيروا
سلوكهم واضاف لكننا حتى الان لا نرى اي
مؤشرات تدل على ان الولايات المتحده
مستعده حتى للتفكير في ضروره العوده الى
الاصول المنصوص عليها في الوثائق
القانونيه الدوليه
في الشرقيه اوكرانيا احرزت القوات الروسيه
تقدما وصف بالهامشي بالمقارنه مع الخسائر
التي تكبدتها على محوري باخموت
لاسيما عدد المركبات المدرعه التي خسرها
فوج الدبابات العاشر الروسي الحديث
التشكيل فلنتابع
بخسائر وصفت بالفادحه تحرز القوات الروسيه
تقدما في مدينه افدي افكا على الجبهه
الغربيه لدونيتس شرق اوكرانيا تقدم يشي
بتكتيك جديد للمعارك الهدف منه باخموت رمز
المقاومه الاوكرانيه
المدينه الواقعه على مسافه 13 كيلومترا
فقط عن دونيسك في دومبس شرق اوكرانيا
ووفقا لزعيم دونانس كالموالي لروسيا
دينسبوشيلين تعطي روسيا امكانيه قطع خط
امداد القوات الاوكرانيه في الشرق بشكل
كامل وتسهيل الهجوم المباشر على فوليدار
اضافه لاحكام الخناق على القوات
الاوكرانيه وقطع الاتصالات والامدادات بين
مقابل تقول وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه ان
التقدم الذي احرزه فوج الدبابات العاشر
الروسي في ابديفكا كان هامشيا مقارنه
بالخسائر الفادحه في المركبات المدرعه لا
سيما ان الفوج شكل حديثا وتلقى تدريبا
مكثفا في بيلاروسيا
هدفنا هو القضاء على اكبر عدد ممكن من
الاعداء وتهيئه الظروف لبدء هجوم مضاد
لدينا هدف وهو الوصول الى حدود اوكرانيا
والقضاء على العدو حتى يموتوا هنا بالقرب
من بخموت ارباح مطامحه بحسب وسائل اعلام
روسيه فان التقدم فيكا رافقه اخر شمال
ضخمه اذ سيطرت قوات فاجنر على مجمع ازوم
الذي يشكل المنطقه الصناعيه في عدا عن
الوصول الى سكه الحديد والتقدم في بعض
المناطق الحضريه تقدم تبقى تكلفته وجدواه
غير معروفين
[موسيقى]
وتتميز ايضا بانظمه الاتصال الموجوده داخل
هذه الدبابات التي تمكنها من مسح دقيق
لارضيات المعركه وتحديد طبعا الاهداف
المعاديه بدقه متناهيه احدى الميزات
الاساسيه مشاهدينا في دبابه تشالنجر 2
تتمثل بالدرع المتقدم الذي يوفر لها مستوى
عالم من الحمايه ضد العديد من التهديدات
وتحديدا عندما يتعلق الامر بالعبوات
الناسفه بالضربات الموجهه ومن مسافه قريبه
تشالنجر تو ستشارك في حرب الى جانب دبابات
الالمانيه التي ارسلتها المانيا في وقت
سابق وعدد هذه الدبابات كان كما نعلم 18
دبابه يذكر ان اوكرانيا تمتلك نحو 300
دبابه فقط منها ما تضرر او اصبح خارج
الخدمه منذ بدايه الحرب الدائره مع روسيا
[موسيقى]
مجلس النواب الامريكيه يسيطر او يسطر
مذكره استدعاء بحق وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه
ويمهله اسبوع فقط للكشف عن وثائق تتعلق
بفوضى الانسحاب من افغانستان في اغسطس من
عام 2021 مذكره الاستدعاء بحقد لينكن تم
توقيعها من قبل رئيس لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه
بمجلس النواب الامريكي مايكل ماكول الذي
كشف ان وزير الخارجيه رفض تقديم برقيه
وردع على البرقيه ورد على البرقيه دفعه
الى اصدار اول مذكره استدعاء بصفته رئيس
اللجنه النائب الجمهوري كان قد اطلق
تحقيقا بشان الانسحاب الفوضوي للقوات
الامريكيه من افغانستان في عهد الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن والاحداث التي شهدتها
البلاد طبعا منذ ذلك الحين وردا على هذه
المذكره وعلى مذكره الاستدعاء قالت وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه لانها مستعده لاتاحه
المعلومات ذات الصله في البرقيه عبر
افادات او اليات اخرى وكان طبعا في وقت
سابق اكدت انها كشفت بالفعل عن المعلومات
وتعمل على تقديم المزيد لكن لا يمكن الكشف
عن بعض التفاصيل الدقيقه الا لمسؤولين
كبار في خطوه تهدف طبعا كما نعلم لحمايه
هويه من عبروا عن او عبروا عن معارضتهم
لهذا الموضوع بعض الجمهوريين
والديمقراطيين يرون انه لا توجد روايه
كامله عن العمليه الفوضويه لانسحاب القوات
الامريكيه من افغانستان والتي ذهب ضحايتها
عينها ثلاثه عشر جنديا امريكيا تحديدا في
مطار كابل صحيفه كانت نشرت تحقيقا تحدث عن
ان اكثر من 20 دبلوماسيا امريكيا في
افغانستان ارسلوا برقيه سريه عبر احدى
القنوات لتحذير بلنكن في عام 2021
وتحديدا في يوليو من احتمال سقوط كابول في
ايدي حركه طالبان مع انسحاب طبعا القوات
الامريكيه من البلاد والذي وصف بالفوضوي
[موسيقى]
للحديث اكثر عن هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
واشنطن مراسل العربيه مساء الخير يعني
بالطلب الذي قدم هناك تركيز على ثلاثه
امور ما هي هذه الامور المطلوبه اليوم
توضيحها لمجلس النواب وما المسار القانوني
لهذا الموضوع
يريد مجلس النواب بقياده الجمهوريين ان
يحقق فعلا بما حدث في الانسحاب اولا هم
غاضبون من انها الرئيس بيض اتخذ قرارا
بالانسحاب بشكل الذي اتخذه به ثانيا لان
هناك عدد من الضحايا الامريكيين الذين
سقطوا في مطار كابول ثالثا يريدون ان
يفهموا اين وصلت الاوضاع بعد هذا القرار
في افغانستان وهل تشكل افغانستان خطرا على
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في ظل حكم
طالبان ووجود القاعده وداعش خراسان
وبالتالي هم يريدون الكشف عن المزيد من
الحقائق خصوصا هذه المذكره وهي مثيره جدا
للاهتمام لان من خلال وزاره الخارجيه
يستطيع الدبلوماسيون ان يرسلوا رساله
اعتراض يعترضون فيها على ما تقوم به
الاداره الامريكيه
يعني هو اعطى بلنكن حتى اليوم حتى انتهاء
اليوم لتقديم ما طلب منه ما المتوقع ان
يحصل بالساعات المقبله
ارسل مكول رئيس لجنه الخارجيه في مجلس
النواب الامريكيه الطلب بالحصول على
المذكره صباح هذا اليوم ومن المنتظر ان
تنتهي المهله التي اعطاها بنقول ليسلم نص
المذكره من قبل الدبلوماسيين يوم الاثنين
المقبل هل يريد بلينكن الافراج عن هذه
المذكره واعطائها لمجلس النواب الجواب هو
لا وربما يلجا الى المحاكم لعرقله هذا
الامر وننتظر الاسبوع المقبل شكرا لك
مراسل العربيه حدثتنا من واشنطن
[موسيقى]
اعلنت حركه طالبان
بانها اعتقلت ناشطه افغانيا في مجال تعليم
الفتيات دون ذكر سبب احتجازه مطيع الله
ويسعى كان يناضل من اجل حق الفتيات في
الدراسه منذ ان منع الطالبان تعليمهن عام
2021 فلنتابع
لم تكتفي طالبان بمنع الفتيات من دخول
الفصول الدراسيه فحسب بلقى الطالبان
القبضه على الناشط الافغنيا بارز في مجال
تعليم الفتيات الافغانيات
الامم المتحده طالبت طالبان بتوضيح سبب
احتجاز مطيع والذي ياتي اعتقاله وسط القبض
على عدد من النشاطات الذين كانوا يناضلون
من اجل تعليم المراه ويسال بالغ من العمر
30 عاما يسافر الى مناطق نائيه من
افغانستان لتحسين فرص حصول جميع الاطفال
على التعليم رغم تلقيه تهديدات كثيره
يدافع ويس الذي ينحدر من اقليم قندهار
جنوبي افغانستان منذ سنوات عن تعليم
الفتيات لاسيما في المناطق الريفيه
المحافظه
وانشا منظمه مسار القلم قائلا ان الخدمات
التعليميه لا تصل لكثير من الفتيات اللا
يعيشن في الريف
تاكلت حقوق المراه تدريجيا منذ عوده
طالبان الى السلطه عام 2021 بعد الانسحاب
الامريكي من اغلاق المدارس والجامعات حتى
يتم خلقه بيئه مناسبه على حد قولهم الى
اعاقه اعمالهن عن طريق منعهن من العمل في
المنظمات غير الحكوميه المحليه والدوليه
باستثناء القطاع الصحي هذا ويتعرضنا
الافغانيات لقيود شديده بطرق اخرى ايضا
حيث اصدر الطالبان مرسوما يقضي بضروره
تغطيه النساء بطريقه تكشف عن اعينهم فقط
ويجب ان يرافقهن قريبا ذكر اذا كنا يسافرن
اكثر من 72 كيلومترا كما تم منع النساء من
دخول الحدائق وصلت الرياضيه رشا خياط
العربيه
[موسيقى]
مستمره
وهي اللحظه
اتاكدت انه ابليس النجوات
النار بالنار دراما رمضانيه تعود وترصد
معاناه السوريين النازحين في لبنان
عندك ماضي مع السوريين بفهمك بس بتحل
مشاكلك راس برا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد نحو 300 مليون عامل
بدوام كامل في كافه القطاعات حول العالم
معرضون لخطر فقدان وظيفتهم والسبب هنا هو
الذكاء الاصطناعي ولهذا الامر ثمن سيؤدي
طبعا الى اضطراب كبير في سوق العمل وفق ما
كشفه تقرير لمصرف جولد من الذي اوضح بان
ربع العمل المنجز في الولايات المتحده وفي
منطقه اليورو يمكن جعله اليا بفضل التقدم
الكبير في مجال الذكاء الاصطناعي مثل تشات
جي بي تي وغير من هذه التطبيقات هذا
المشهد يمكن ان يؤدي الى طفره انتاجيه من
شانها زياده الناتج المحلي الاجمالي
العالمي السنوي بنسبه 7% على مدى العشر
سنوات المقبله الارقام كشفت هنا ايضا
مشاهدينا بان ثلثي الوظائف في الولايات
المتحده واوروبا معرضه لدرجه معينه من
تحولها الى اليه جراء الذكاء الاصطناعي
والمحامون والموظفون الاداريون من بين
اولئك الاكثر عرضه لخطر الاستغناء عن بعض
مهامهم نحو سبعه بالمئه من العاملين في
الولايات المتحده يعملون في وظائف يمكن
انجاز نصف مهامهم فيها على الاقل بواسطه
الذكاء الاصطناعي وهم عرضه للاستبدال طبعا
والابحاث مماثله بالنسبه لاوروبا في
المقابل تحدثت صحيفه واشنطن بوست في وقت
سابق هذا الاسبوع ان الذكاء الاصطناعي لم
يحتل الوظائف بعض واوضحت ان الذكاء
الاصطناعي يشق الطريق بشكل متزايد عبر
الصناعات المختلفه ويغير طبعا شكل ومضمون
الوظائف بدايه من الطب مرورا بالبيع
بالتجزئه حتى التسويق والكتابه
[موسيقى]
للحديث اكثر عن هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا
عبر زوم من الكويت الدكتور محمد قاسم
استاذ سابق في كليه الدراسات التكنولوجيه
دكتور يعني عندما نتحدث عن امكانيه حلول
الذكاء الاصطناعي مكان الكثير من المهارات
والوظائف الى اي مدى هذا الموضوع قريب
يعني وقابل للتطبيق بسرعه خصوصا ان
التشكيك في بعض ما يحل اليوم مكان مهارات
كان موجود وهو الان يعني حل مكان الكثير
من الوظائف
اهلا وسهلا فيكم نعم بالنسبه لحل وظائف
غير معروف وحتى في ورقه صدرت من اوبن اي
اي بالتعاون مع جامعه فنسلفانيا تتحدث عن
هذا الموضوع باسهاب طرحه جميع الوظائف
التي ممكن ان تتاثر وطرحه حتى الوظائف
التي لن تتاثر والغريب ان معظم هذه
الوظائف هي وظائف اعتياديه حرفيه يدويه
مثل طباخ غسان غسان الصحون
من تقرير بان الوظائف التي كنا نعتبرها
يعني وظائف عاديه يمكن ان يكون هناك
مهارات اكبر بوظائف اخرى هي في المستقبل
وظائف ستستمر يعني بشكل مختلف عن الوظائف
الاخرى
هل هذا يعني تعزيزه بالضبط صحيح الوظائف
التي تحتاج الى عقل او الى ابداع كبير او
الى عقول متميزه هذه ربما لن تتاثر في هذه
الايام لكن الوظائف التي ستعتمد على بعض
انواع الذكاءات البشريه المعتاده هذه راح
تتاثر مباشره على سبيل المثال لو كان هناك
مبرمج يستعين
لاعطاء بعض المساعده في البرامج او في
البرمجه من السهوله جدا ان تستعيد الشركه
عن الكثير من المبرمجين الموجودين عندهم
وخصوصا الذين يدفع لهم مبالغ كبيره
للاستعاذه بهم في
مبرمجين اعتياديين يستعينون فاذا الوظائف
من هذه النوع ستتاثر بكل تاكيد لكن غير
واضح لهذا الموضوع الى الان
التفكير النقدي تفكير استراتيجي الابداع
التعاطف الخيال المها رات الجسديه
والدرايه الفنيه كلها مجالات لن تتاثر
بالذكاء الاصطناعي طبعا بدرجه معينه هذا
يعني حمايه اي نوع من الوظائف
كما ذكرت الوظائف اللي فيها حرفيه يدويه
هذه راح تبقى لفتره طويله الى ان تدخل
الروبوتات في هذا الجانب لكن لا يزال حتى
الوظائف اللي فيها الابداع او الكتابه او
التحليل الان نحن نلاحظ ان تي ياخذ مساحه
من اللي كان ياخذ البشر في هذا الجانب
فاذا هذه الوظائف ايضا ستتاثر لكن بدرجات
مختلفه
ولكن انظري الى المستقبل القريب اذا كان
هذا اربعه او جي بي تي 4 فتخيلي كيف سيكون
الذكاء الاصطناعي اذا وصلنا الى مرحله
عشره الى عشره عند ذلك اعتقد الوظائف
ستتاثر بشكل كبير جدا من البشر يعني نحن
نقول الذكاء ليس له ستاندر معين ولكن هكذا
سيصبح البشر اغبياء مقارنه بهذا الذكاء
دكتور يعني عندما ناخذ الجانب الاخر وهو
جانب زياده الانتاج بالدول والناتو
والزياده بالناتج المحلي كيف يمكن يعني
لهذه لهذا الذكاء ان يزيد من الناتج
المحلي في الدول
بكل تاكيد
اي وظيفه تستغل اليوم الذكاء الاصطناعي
سيزيد الانتاج عندها بشكل كبير جدا
وستتخلف اي شركه لن تستخدم الذكاء
الاصطناعي وقد تكلمت عن هذا الموضوع
بتحديد عن استخدام تشاد عندنا في المنطقه
وللاسف طبعا نحن لدينا في المنطقه وخصوصا
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه لا يزال
محظور ولم تصل اليه الامكانيه الى الان
فهذه الامكانيه توفر للدول
انتاجيه سريعه فبدلا من ان تنتج الاشياء
في يوم واحد تنتجها في خلال ساعات بسيطه
جدا فالانتاجيه
ستزيد بسرعه
ومعها الاقتصاد
زياده
الانتاجيه وايضا الحلول مكان عدد كبير من
الوظائف يعني هذا الانتقال هذه العمليه
النوعيه من الانتقال بالمجتمعات بالحكومات
هي بدات منذ فتره مع كل الثوره
التكنولوجيه التي دخلت هذا النوع من
الذكاء الاصطناعي لك اي مده زمنيه نتحدث
لكي يصبح امر واقع وحقيقه
في الواقع هو الان نحن في فتره انتقاليه
لا نعلم بالضبط ما الذي سيحدث كل الدراسات
التي ترينها الان ستتغير مع الوقت وسنرى
فعلا ما الذي سيحدث للسوق يعني لا ننسى ان
ازاله شخص من وظيفه معينه لا يعني انه لا
توجد له وظيفه اخرى في مكان اخر كل ما
هنالك نريد ان نصل الى مرحله استقرار
لنعرف ما الذي يحدث بهذه التكنولوجيا
التكنولوجيا جديده جدا وهناك تجارب عديده
عليها الى ان يستقر الموضوع ونصل الى
مرحله اي دول اليوم ببنيه الاقتصاديه
بتركيب الماليه الاجتماعيه وحتى الحكوميه
قادره ان تكون يعني الاولى التي تدخل هكذا
تقنيه على نظام المستقبلي
بكل تاكيد الولايه المتحده لازالت الصين
متاخره في هذا الجانب وهناك يعني تساؤلات
ما الذي حدث للصين في استخراج نموذج لغه
كبير
لحد الحين ولكن اوروبا ايضا بشكل عام لان
الباب مفتوح لها في استغلال هذه
التكنولوجيا بسرعه
وعموما حتى عندنا في المنطقه الجروس عالي
لو فتح المجال لجميع الدول الاستخدامها
شكرا لك استاذ محمد قاسم استاذ سابق في
كليه الدراسات التكنولوجيه حدثنا من
الكويت
[موسيقى]
اظهر مقطع فيديو نشرته اداره شرطه
اداره الشرطه صورا لامراه
تقتحم مدرسه مسيحيه
بندققيتين ومسدس في هجوم مسلح اودى بحياه
سته اشخاص بينهم ثلاثه اطفال بعد اطلاق
نار مكثف داخل اروقه مدرسه في الولايات
المتحده
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وفي مكان الامريكيون يترقبون كلمه رئيس
الامريكيه جو بايدن حول مذبحه المدرسه في
ناشفيل فوجئوا برئيسهم يتحدث عن حبه
للايسكريم فلنستمع الى ما قاله باي
[موسيقى]
حبه
عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ندت بكلام
بايدن بعض التعليقات طالبت باقالته من
منصبه لان كلامه يشير الى ان عقله غير
سليم البعض الاخر اعتبر ان كلام بعيدا
يشكل احراجا كبيرا للولايات المتحده
واصوات اخرى اعتبرت ان كل من صوت لبعيد
عليه ان يشعر بالعار والاهانه
[موسيقى]
ومن المدينه المنوره الى العالم هو اخر
المشاريع التطويريه التي شهدتها المنطقه
المركزيه بالمسجد النبوي والذي يقع على
مساحه 20000 متر مربع ويضم 18 مطبخا من
مختلف البلدان الاسلاميه لتتناسب مع كافه
اذواق الزائرين طوال شهر رمضان التفاصيل
برفقه الزميل سلطان السلمي
[موسيقى]
المدينه المنوره تعتبر ثاني اهم مدينه
للعالم الاسلامي حيث تضم المسجد النبوي
وقبر النبي محمد حيث يفد اليها سنويا اكثر
من ثمانيه ملايين مسلم من شتى بقاع الارض
الان المنطقه صارت جدا جدا مكتظه بالحجاج
والمعتمرين التوجيه صار على جهه واحده
تركيز الحجاج كلهم صار على جهه واحده
المساحات صارت اكبر تعدد الثقافات
فرصه تجاره جدا جدا كويسه في المنطقه هذه
من المدينه المنوره الى العالم هو عنوان
مشروع المنطقه المركزيه المجاور للمسجد
النبوي الذي يقع على مساحه
20,000 متر مربع ويضم ثمانيه عشر مطبخا من
مختلف البلدان الاسلاميه
لتتناسب مع كافه اذواق الزائرين طوال شهر
رمضان اضافه الى مركز استعلامات
ومحله لبيع التذكارات ومسارات مهيئه الى
ساحات المسجد الحقيقه المكان رائع جدا هذه
الاختلاف
التعدد الدول بالاكلات والمطاعم الرقابه
الجميله الرائعه جدا يعني واحد من ياكل
مامن انه مطمئنا اني اكل هنا بهذا الاماكن
هي جوار وطمانينه هي مدينه الرسول عليه
الصلاه والسلام فاني لمست هاي الطمانينه
اللي احنا افتقدناها لسنوات طويله بالعراق
لكن اذا احب اشتري اشياء تذكاريه اشياء
كثيره يعني اشياء السجادات الاسلاميه
[موسيقى]
السلاسل الاسلاميه انا احب اكون اولادي
يتذكرون العمره اللي اني سويتها باشياء
جميله بيها طابع تراثي سعودي اسهمت
المشروعات الحديثه التي انجزت في المنطقه
المركزيه بالمدينه المنوره في تحسين
المشهد الحضري ورفع مستوى جوده الحياه في
الطرق والشوارع المحيطه
وتهيئتها بشكل اكبر للمشاه وقاصدي المسجد
النبوي الشريف من المدينه المنوره سلطان
السلمي العربيه
[موسيقى]
تعود قصص اللاجئين السوريين الى الشاشه
وهذه المره في لبنان التي يجسدها مسلسل
النار بالنار المسلسل الجدلي المكون من 30
حلقه يعرض موضوع النزوح والمشاكل التي
ترافق هذا الموضوع يجمع المسلسل عابد فهد
وكريس بشار وجورج خباز بالاضافه الى اهم
الفنانين السوريين واللبنانيين المزيد في
فقره كواليس مع سهى الوعل واعداد ايهم
القاسم
[موسيقى]
حاول يكون عزيز عامل شيدو السوريه
بدنا نقطع الكهرباء عن الحاره
مرحبا
مثيره للفضول هذا العام في رمضان مسلسل
للنار بالنار والسبب جراه موضوع ولد تناول
بعض المشاكل اللي تواجه اللاجئين السوريين
في لبنان بجراه كبيره من بطوله النجمين
عابد فهد وكاريس بشار حاولنا نوصل فكره
جدا موضوعيه ونكون جدا وسطيين وما نكون
ميالين لطرف اكثر من طرف كونه خلفيه هذا
المسلسل بيحكي عن الصراع السوري اللبناني
يلي سببه
بس على الصعيد الانساني بتكتشف انه حقيقه
ما في خلاف على الصعيد الانساني ولكن في
رواسب عديده
والام وجروح طبعا نزلت على المنطقه
الاساسيه اللي هي عايشه فيها بسوريا
اكيد كل السوريين بيعرفوها اسمها الشيخ
محي الدين ومن هناك انطلقت بانه مريم كيف
بتمشي وليش هيك بتمشي المسلسل المؤلف من
30 حلقه من تاليف رامي كوسا واخراج محمد
عبد العزيز يشارك فيه بالبطوله ايضا
الفنانين جورج خباز الطوني عيسى زينه مكي
طارق تميم وكثير غيرهم ويحظى حاليا بنسبه
مشاهده عاليه وسط الكثير من الجدل على
مواقع التواصل ما بين فئات تعزز الاحداث
كواقع وافئات تصف بالمبالغه الرؤيه الفنيه
والمعالجه انا برايي انه كيف ممكن نحن
نتطرق لهذه الاشكاليه بدون ما يكون له شكل
اخباري او نيوز يعني كيف يتم معالجته
دراميا هون اهميه هذا المشروع مسلسل نار
بالنار بعتقد اول مسلسل مشترك لبناني سوري
مبرر عم يحكي عن هالصراع ما بين الشعبين
والصداقات كمان مش بس الصراعات فمسلسل
حقيقي جدا شخصيه انطوائيه عنده اسباب
وعنده تاريخه بين فقط بالحرب
وخاطفينه بوقتها السوريين فعنده اذا بدك
حقد كبير على السوريين وهذا الشيء بيترجمه
بتعاطيه مع الناجحين السوريين يلي بيكونوا
اللي بيجوا على على الحاره اللي هو ساكن
فيها انا عم بلعب شخصيه
مواطن عادي اسمه جميل كان صحافه وهو يساري
شيوعي يعني صار عنده انكسار من الثوره
بالبلد وصار عنده انكسار من انتماءه
السياسي من خطه سياسي اللي ماشي
الحياه ما بصير تلعب معها
وهي اللحظه
اتاكدت انه ابليس اللي جواتي
طلعوا
من هون للشيخ الهندي
عندك ماضي مع الس
وريين تحل مشاكل
[موسيقى]
الى اسبانيا حيث يواصل رجال الاطفاء
محاربه الحريق الهائل الذي دمر 4300 هكتار
من الغابات في شرق البلاد مدفعه حوالي 18
شخص على ترك منازلهم والهروب منها فلنتابع
ختام التاسعه مع العلوي
اكثر من مليونير متظاهر ضد النظام التقاعد
في فرنسا يصر على التعديل
ثم يشكرك
يعتبر عوده واشنطن الى المبادئ المتحضره
بين الدول شرطا لاستئناف الحوار
مذكره استدعاء لوزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
للمثولي امام الكونجرس بسبب الانسحاب من
افغانستان
الاصطناعي من العالم 300 مليون وظيفه
مهدده عالميا
مشاهدينا الى هنا الى ختام التاسعه لكن
طبعا اخبار العالميه مستمره كما كل ليله
والان الى 360 وزميله راويه راويه مساء
الخير ماذا لديك مساء الخير ليال طبعا
الاحتجاجات الحاشده والمشتعله في شوارع
باريسيا اهم مواضيعنا وايضا جديد
الميدانيات والحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا